une bonne nouvelle pour patrick dils à
moins d'un mois de son nouveau procès en
assises un rapport de la gendarmerie
serait susceptible de le mettre hors de
cause dans la sphère du double meurtre
d'enfants de montigny-lès-metz les
enquêteurs ont entendu de nouveaux
témoins il affirme que le mode
opératoire ressemble fort à celui de
francis heaulme le tueur en série
isabelle brice dit grimbert francis
heaulme at il tué cyril et alexandra
coups de pierres en automne 86 selon le
républicain lorrain ce serait fort
probable pour la première fois le tueur
en série aurait affirmé être monté sur
le talus et même avoir touché le corps
de l'un des enfants
une déclaration que son avocate balaie
d'un revers de la main pressé de
questions par les gendarmes a reconnu un
certain nombre de choses a dit j'étais
large effet si j'ai fait ça et il a
immédiatement rétracter ses affirmations
alors je crois que c'est un petit peu
inquiétant quelque part qu'on publie
comme ça des éléments extraits d'un
rapport qu'on publie les termes les plus
percutants qu'on les retire de leur
contexte et que finalement on dénature
la substance du rapport en question
manifestement les gendarmes tout sérieux
qu'ils puissent être dans le cadre de
cette enquête tout j'allais dire tout
sérieux dans le sens de vouloir
absolument impliquer own se font aussi
balader parole alors oui il est
impartial ce rapport
je trouve qu'il est quelque part un peu
partial parce qu'il est fait dans le
sens de vouloir absolument enfin prouver
que heaulme serait là sur les lieux au
moment du clean et aurait commis ce
crime pour les 'deals' en revanche si le
rapport n'apporte rien de nouveau il
rétablit la vérité surtout en ce qui
concerne l'heure du crime
les gendarmes la situe en fin d'après
midi or à ce moment là la famille et se
trouvaient encore dans la meuse la
travail des gendarmes a été très très
bien fait parce qu'ils ont entendu au
moins plus de plus d'une centaine de
personnes et qui conforte qu'est ce qui
a été dit a dit au départ et dont
personne n'a voulu tenir compte
ce rapport met en cause
l' enquête de la police qui a été fêtée
à 15 ans cette pénultième version des
faits va-t-elle plaidé en faveur du
jeune homme incarcéré depuis 15 ans
condamné à deux reprises patrick dils
doit être jugé pour la troisième fois à
lyon le mois prochain
du jamais vu dans les annales de la
justice